el gobierno británico está estudiando
cuando convoca unas nuevas elecciones en
Irlanda del Norte posiblemente la
primera semana de marzo para garantizar
que haya más avances en las
negociaciones entre Londres y Bruselas
para modificar el protocolo de esta
región que mantiene a Irlanda del Norte
en un estatus diferente creó una
frontera comercial en el mar de Irlanda
lo que ha generado que por ejemplo
cualquier producto que va a ser enviado
desde cualquier región británica a
Irlanda del Norte el mismo país sea un
tipo de exportación por el acuerdo de
paz de 1998 el gobierno regional en
Irlanda del Norte debe ser una coalición
entre los republicanos del chinfein y
los unionistas del dvp hablamos en
France 24 con la ministra primera
ministra de Irlanda del Norte michelonil
que nos habla sobre el si el acuerdo de
paz está comprometido Con la falta de un
ejecutivo
meses atrás tuvimos unas elecciones y es
muy importante que esa lección y el
resultado sean respetados el público
votó en gran mayoría para que la
política funcione quieren que nos
sentemos en la mesa y formemos un
ejecutivo no hay una salida alternativa
tiene que funcionar pero creo que
desafortunadamente estamos atrapados por
el desorden del brexit que el partido
unionista democrático ayudó A causar con
sus amigos en la derecha del partido
conservador Londres y Bruselas avanzan
en estas negociaciones con el ojo
vigilante de Estados Unidos que fue
garante del proceso de paz de 1998 y se
espera que haya un acuerdo para celebrar
el aniversario 25 del acuerdo de paz del
viernes Santo